how's going bros my name is Pippa today
we're gonna check out an awesome new app
that I found online your brothers have
been suggesting that I check it out it's
called Face Swap life it means we will a
space swap life now this game is a lot
more fun with friends but do you see any
friends around here no they are not here
so we're just gonna go ahead and swap
faces with my dog please work okay make
a face okay make a face damn it and get
make a face damn it I can make a face
Jim let's try Maya well isn't this the
greatest video in a long time eh
ah here we are okay so this is my face
this is my face and a baby oh my god
[ __ ] do you like my hair how much I'm
gonna be the president mom sure honey
sure you're gonna be as president one
day that's just weird what does my eyes
look so dead oh I get it they have two
dead oh no oh God
legally blah
Oh God some furry fantasies coming real
this is like phase rig but [ __ ]
creepier I don't even know man
I don't even know man what am i grumpy
cat oh oh my that's sweet buddy mate so
creepy oh god hahaha oh my god
this is weird oh god
Oh Jack Cecil me now oh this is get it
off
Oh Jack it off my face Jack what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
hahaha hi everyone its markup like hey
that hair looks good on me
I got a probably get a haircut ah ok
let's do that the terrifying swap
oh no no mark please no mark I'm sorry
mark oh this is the greatest thing oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god this
is ridiculous howdy y'all I'm from the
south and I like barbecue oh free
healthcare Oh Oh No those eyebrows are
taking over my face
ah those eyebrows are not good for
anyone man I'm sorry can you need to
pluck them Mary Mary tell Ken to pluck
his eyebrow
ASAP Jesus Christ search for faces on
the internet oh my god that's awesome
you can literally just load it directly
from Google oh my god okay what happens
if my god I can't believe I didn't think
about this sooner oh that is not good
for anyone man all right friends I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did leave
a like I gotta try this with mice as
well I tried in live space what please
leave a like let me know if you want me
to do more of these and if so let me
know whose faces you want to be swamped
and that's it for me for now it's always
thanks for watching and stay awesome